[Music]
one of the people you can trust is
family
hi this is luke grimes and i play casey
on yellowstone we're looking for a blue
two-toned van going north on 540. when
you're a little boy and you want to be
an actor what are what are some things
you want to play a cowboy a soldier you
know it's just kind of all of the dream
roles you know wrapped into one and he's
just a emotionally complex
guy but also kind of a badass i mean
it's it's it's all the good stuff
leave or i'm calling the police i am the
police now open the gate
you do realize too now that you've
solidified yourself as one of america's
hottest on-screen cowboys oh god what
kind of reaction do you get in your
everyday life uh well i live in montana
now so i don't really see human beings
anymore i think there's more cows than
people in my county uh but when i do
have to venture out things have changed
you know from
from like say season one to now uh the
airport's a little hairier it's obvious
it's it's got a far reach are you casey
to them or are you luke oh casey all the
way which uh big shoes to fill you know
[Laughter]
everybody now
let's take it back to the very beginning
the casting process
for this show what was that like the
moment i heard taylor shared it and i
was on board i don't care what it is let
me in
uh then i read it and i was you know
casey's
out of everything i've ever read
i can say hands down with my my favorite
part that i've ever auditioned for and i
got a call from taylor probably three
days later saying you got the job now
you got to go go get on a horse
[Music]
okay
so cowboy boot camp tell me about this
yeah so you know obviously taylor has to
hire a bunch of kind of la city slickers
to play these cowboys so he sends us on
a cowboy camp it's basically a three-day
uh
uh pack trip into the middle of nowhere
uh you know we're kind of sleeping in
tents you know
resting our heads against our saddles
the uh a lot of things went wrong which
made it even more cowboy than it was
supposed to be what went wrong uh one of
the mules kind of took a tumble and we
lost a lot of our food uh for one of the
nights
so we had to find some this is a real
life organ trail over here it was good
though you know it it not only built
some camaraderie between uh you know the
cast but uh you know learned a few
things it's one thing to ride a horse
around an arena and another to like you
know jump over creeks and have your
horse get spooked because of a snake and
you know going through kind of some of
the real life stuff
looking at the new season and just
watching yourself on a horse and seeing
how far you've come what's that like you
know it's it's a kind of a skill set i
never saw coming you know i didn't i
didn't
really think horses would have been a
part of my life once you get the bug
it's pretty special and it took me a
while you know i'll be honest for the
first couple seasons i was still a
little nervous getting on a horse and
now it's i really look forward to it
when this show is over i'm gonna have to
figure out getting some of my own
because i'm gonna miss it
shooting in montana let's talk a little
bit about that what would you say
the just that location lends to
the story and how it inspires you guys i
think the location it's probably the
biggest character in the show
you know i think it's why it's part of
the
the reason why the show's been such a
success you know people want to be there
it's and i obviously there's something
to it i moved there like i literally you
know it would be i would go from la
to shoot and then go back home and then
at a certain point i would go back to
l.a like why am i here
i like it so much better where i just
was there's definitely like
this
romantic ideal to to the west you know
just fighting for that dream of of the
old american west
neighbor
i think taylor is
one of the best writers there is
and he's really riding in his sweet spot
which is you know he's a real cowboy hey
hey taylor is legitimately a cowboy and
uh
you know it's the perfect world for him
and he knows it like the back of his
hand and you know it's a pleasure to be
you know in that world
and save your allowance one day you
might get a horse like this
but i doubt it
taylor knows how it ends and he's told
me that he's like i know exactly how
this ends i get to be on this ride too
which is really fun
how would you describe
season four the beginning of season four
is one of the most exciting things i i
have ever seen on tv and then for casey
the rest of season four is sort of a
bit of a healing process and i think
season four for him is kind of a game
changer where
you really set some things up for him to
be a different man in season five
so explain to us
the healing process that casey is going
through in the significance of the wolf
that keeps showing up for him you know
it's funny when that wolf kept showing
up in season three
and um i've learned not to really ask
questions when it comes to stuff like
that because it's it's more fun to
to experience things sort of the way the
audience does you know i'm just going
script to script and and i kept being
like this wolf must mean something you
know wolf is our protector
your spirit animal it's obviously some
sort of
spirit that's kind of you know calling
to casey and and mo
recognizes that and basically tells him
it's time to kind of go figure that out
for himself
not sure i believe in all this
it sure believes in you he goes on
sort of a vision quest
which is definitely something right like
i mean your credit to taylor you just i
didn't see it coming i'm like it's so
not the show it's just so something
different so it's its own kind of
journey and i remember reading that and
being like wow that is just you know you
never know what he's going to write next
oh you know when i'm done
how will you know casey
that is the question
going into the ritual he's sort of uh
doubting the process right like he
doesn't quite get what he's doing
[Music]
so casey doing the ritual outside all
alone in the cold what was it like
shooting that when i read it i was you
know just so excited to kind of do the
the emotional life of that scene but
what i didn't realize is that
usually when
you do the native
american vision quest which is a real
thing that people do
you do it
naked
so
it was an 18 degree day
and taylor didn't make me do it naked
but i had to uh i was basically in my
underwear
um and it was one of those days where it
was like raining and snowing at the same
time it just couldn't have been a more
miserable day for for weather for most
of it
uh and yeah and there i was for about 12
hours uh in my underwear
honestly that's the toughest day of
shooting of my whole career hands down i
will say you know gator who plays the
chef in the show he's he's actually our
real craft services guy so he he really
does make us all food and kind of take
care of us and
uh he made me a hot toddy and that
changed my life it was it was the
greatest beverage i've ever had in my
life how far into shooting did you get
the hot toddy uh let's see i showed up
at six in the morning i got the hot
toddy around four okay it was but it was
perfection it changed the whole game
yeah so thanks gator
good
morning so season four explores this
evolution
of casey and john's relationship as
father and son and it seems
really solid
talk us through that evolution i think
what's cool about their relationship is
they've they've kind of learned how to
heal it without
coming to any resolution they still
might disagree but they've been able to
move past that and just
you know learn how to work together
through those sort of disagreements
afford to do this
you know we can't afford not to son
no anymore i love that relationship i've
never seen a father and son relationship
portrayed quite like it you know
where you have these two men who are
very
strong-willed hard-headed
who love each other and are able to kind
of show each other that without you know
really giving too much away about how
they feel about each other
a good man casey
sometimes good men have to do real bad
things
now another relationship for casey is
obviously with
monica this is it
yeah i think so too
describe their relationship this season
it's just non-stop for them you know
it's it's
a [ __ ] storm and
i think what's really cool about casey
monica is you can tell they're kind of
twin souls you know they they're meant
to be together they love each other and
uh and nothing can get in between that
and everything has tried you know
i love you
this season
you
you see a very distraught sort of worn
down monica just she she just wants it
to be over with
the whole
dutton fiasco and all that and just get
back to the lives that they they might
have had and i think for casey he's kind
of in between a rock and a hard place
you know it's uh
he cares so deeply about monica and tate
but also
he has this family legacy with the
duttons that you know he's loyal to and
so those two things really uh you know
caused some tension for them and now the
duttons are expanding because in episode
eight monaco reveals she's pregnant
you're gonna be a brother
you having a baby
what was your reaction when you saw that
uh that was cool i'm like hoping that
kelsey gets to wear the big baby bump
it's like that'll be fun and i'm sure
you know obviously like casey is
thrilled how cool right you know that's
that's his dream i think
his he's just he's a family guy you know
he wants he wants his kids and his wife
and his
you know little piece of heaven in
montana somewhere and i can definitely
relate to that
you're happy right
i'm happy
[Music]
one thing i love about casey at the end
of the day is despite
all the things that are trying to tear
him in different directions he's just
such a good man and we see that in his
faith in his brother jamie too
i just don't think jamie could ever do
it dad
i think it's like a
it's just a part of his character to try
to do that with everyone
um i think he gives you the benefit of
the doubt until the very last second and
then
well then
it's a problem
but you know obviously with jamie he's
he he he wants to see the good in
everyone and especially his family you
know and
i love that relationship
i love you brother
i love you if you had to pick what's
your favorite scene from season four
that that shootout in episode one was
pretty damn fun to shoot i'll be honest
that was that was a hoot
okay so i have to ask i'm very curious
obviously you have a background that
includes american sniper which is
directed by clint eastwood who obviously
knows a thing or two about westerns
did any of those
skills or anything picked up lessons
learned did any of that translate into
yellowstone at all funny story about
american sniper
john lynson and taylor sheridan our show
creators went to see that
in the theater together
and
taylor was riding yellowstone and john
called me
and said
bro we loved sniper
taylor's writing apart for this
young navy seal cowboy guy
and that was like two years before i
ever got the script
and i talked to taylor on the first for
the first time on the phone right after
he saw american sniper and he said i
think you'd be great for this casey rule
so that just random story but
funny that you asked about it
and i love that there was that full
circle moment it's funny the way the
universe works especially like being on
brothers and sisters with dave animal
and then he was also in yellowstone too
like that's
do you as an actor is that normal for
things like that serendipitous to happen
or were you guys like oh this this is
cool hey good to see you again i guess
you know hollywood can be kind of a
small world uh in some ways um
if there was one person i would you know
love for that to happen with it would be
dave annabelle because he's freaking
awesome and we were all so sad to see
him go after
episode one uh but yeah it was the life
of the party i mean we had like a save
dave campaign we were like can he come
back as like a ghost please something
speaking of brothers and sisters that's
also where e.t first met you
back in the day and we have a clip to
show you oh no i started playing drums
in church when i was 13 or 14 and
i play drums in a band out here but i
also play
the guitar and you know sing to myself
that doesn't
not for anyone else just yet shower car
bedroom
uh
hallway whenever no one else is around
i'm singing
better believe it oh my god that's crazy
what's going through what's going
through your mind seeing this oh my god
well
like who is that guy it's you
wow that's insane wow are you proud of
yourself how far you've come i mean
i guess i'm i'm i'm happy with my life
you know
i wake up every day i feel so lucky i
get to live where i live and be married
to my wife and
yeah so sure i'm proud of myself yeah
why not you mentioned the music and
you're always playing music
can we see casey sing on yellowstone
that would be weird if casey started
saying but
i think it
here pretty soon you'll you'll see luke
oh oh this is great yeah
whose idea was that
that guy this guy's this guy you heard
him he told you you're 24 year old
wow well luke congratulations on
everything and thank you so much for
taking time to chat with us on behalf of
the fans thank you for all you do in
bringing the magic of casey dutton on
our screens well thanks for having me
it's been awesome
[Music]
you